if anybody here is not familiar with
james bowman dotnet i recommend actually
i order everybody to go to that that
website Jim Bowman's reviews of movies
and his his articles on cultural and
political topics but I want to
particularly say about his movie reviews
treats the genre with a level of
aesthetic seriousness and moral
seriousness that most people don't think
the genre deserves he he is known as he
is known for being highly highly
critical he can't understand why
somebody would read a movie review just
to get another rave about a movie that's
fun to watch he reveals levels of depth
and interest in every movie he writes
about far beyond any other work of media
criticism that's being done in the
United States and his oeuvre over the
past 16 years on that subject is really
an immense accomplishment in the midst
of all of this frequent writing he has
over the past five years been working on
a big book his first book it has just
been published by encounter books there
are copies available for sale in the
ante room the title is honor a history I
urged him to title it honor what it was
where it went and how we could get some
of it back I believe it is the first
book that has ever been written on the
subject of honor there are bits and
pieces in other books both the ancient
and contemporary their works of
anthropology about aspects of Honor but
as a organizing idea as a concept as a
mode of behavior I there has never been
anything like this immensely original
and of I must say extremely enjoyable
and edifying book the idea of honor
as explained by Bowman is ancient it is
in many respects primitive but it is
very much a human idea and has been an
immensely important part of the saga of
human history up until very very
recently I think he would date it at
World War one it was like all human
institutions highly imperfect it
performed many functions whose dish
itude is in evidence as he illustrates
in many aspects of our culture in the
West and in many important areas of
international relations among cultures
and nations including especially the
current conflict between the west and
the terrorist elements of radical Islam
I'm delighted that he would come here
tonight to talk about his book and I
want to move aside and give him the
podium right away after he speaks John
O'Sullivan a senior fellow at the Hudson
Institute former editor and chief of
National Review and currently one of its
editors at large will provide commentary
Jim Bowman resident fellow at the ethics
and Public Policy Center movie reviewer
cultural and political critic and author
of the new book honor a history Jim
thank you Chris as always you're much
too kind I saw a funny television
commercial the other day there were no
words but only a musical soundtrack and
pictures of a fat guy of about my own
age as he realizes that he's grown too
big and so begins a new regimen of
exercise and eating right both of which
things he's supposed to be comically
unfamiliar with but as he sticks with it
and gradually becomes more svelte over
the course of a minute we listened to
the gravelly voiced Bob Dylan on a 1960s
vintage recording as he sings that times
they are a-changin and then the ad cuts
away and up on the screen pops the name
of the sponsor Kaiser Permanente along
with the written exhortation be your own
cause be your own cause is about as good
as summary as you could hope for of the
ethos of the generation to which I
belong the post-war baby boomers indeed
it could be argued that for all our self
congratulatory idealism be your own
cause was our watchword back in the 60s
to an era which so many of us continue
to regard with misty-eyed nostalgia when
hundreds of thousands of us descended on
Washington to say hell no we won't go
what else were we doing but proclaiming
that we not our country or indeed
anything else outside ourselves were our
own cause when we gathered at Woodstock
for three days of peace and love our
high ideals in action consisted of
grooving to the music getting high and
getting laid it sure beat getting shot
at in the jungles of Vietnam for some
cause we'd found it easy to reject in
favor of ourselves but those of us who
remember those days are likely still to
think of ourselves as rebels and
idealists because by making ourselves
our own
we actually did topple a repressive
system and effect a liberation whose
consequences we continue to feel today
true the repressive system which I shall
call the Western honour culture was by
that time not very repressive in fact it
had been knocked around pretty badly for
half a century before we got to it and
it was almost on its last legs by then
anyway all it took was a little push
from us and at least in comparison with
previous revolutions hardly any
self-sacrifice we were our own cause
remember and the whole thing just
collapsed nowadays hardly anyone even
knows what honor means or what it once
meant let me pause then to explain what
I think it means in a few words it's the
good opinion of people who matter to us
the people who matter to us are what I
call the honor group you will have
noticed right away how on a differs from
morality the principles of morality are
universally true in all times and places
but what is honorable will depend to
some extent on the composition of the
honor group looking good in their eyes
thus becomes for the individual a
greater cause than himself even than
saving his own life hence the expression
death before dishonor you don't hear
very often anymore the dominant on a
group in European countries used to be
socially and economically determined and
largely confined to a hereditary
aristocracy but honor underwent a
revolution in the 18th century suddenly
the honor group expanded enormously an
America led the way in fact the American
Revolution was more revolutionary in
this way than in any other George
Washington and the founding fathers
taught the world at all men and not just
a hereditary elite could aspire to honor
and their lesson was echoed by the
European romantics especially sir walter
scott and the popular novelists who came
after him that synthesis of progressive
political ideas and traditional honor
reached its Apogee under the Victorians
with the idea of the Christian gentleman
but it is now
but gone you may regard this as a good
thing or a bad thing nowadays even many
conservatives are likely to regard it as
a bad thing but it is important to
recognize that there are large parts of
the world in which the native on our
culture has remained untouched by those
social forces which have brought down
our own among these are the parts of the
world where America's and the West's
Islamist enemies come from so it is
helpful in understanding them and
therefore in understanding the conflict
in which we are engaged if we try for a
moment to recapture what it is like to
live in an honour culture in order to do
that however we have first to realize
that there are no culture and our own
when we had one or very different things
you only have to think of the phenomenon
of the honour killing in large parts of
the world and not only the Islamic parts
women who are guilty of unchaste
behavior or even of behavior which to
which unchastity might conceivably be
imputed such as going out alone with a
with a boyfriend or wearing revealing
clothes or makeup are commonly killed by
their own fathers husbands or brothers
for having brought dishonor on the
family that kind of thing was a rarity
in the West even back in the days when
the honour culture was strong it's one
of many ways in which our on a culture
when we had one differed from those to
be found elsewhere in the world or take
another example we know that not only
the Bush administration but virtually
every intelligence service in the world
and even Saddam Hussein's own senior
military staff up until January of 2003
fervently believed in the existence of
usable weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq weapons which no one has since been
able to find and why were we so firmly
persuaded of this because Saddam
wouldn't allow inspectors in and
otherwise kept acting as if he had
something to hide and he did have
something to hide 24 in an honor culture
concerned above all with not losing face
and persuading one's enemies that one is
a formidable adversary it was much more
likely to have hidden as he did hide the
fact that he didn't have the weapons
then that he did have them it's not
surprising that we didn't understand
this idea of honor when you consider
that we also largely ceased to
understand the one that was our own
there were several reasons why the
Islamic Honor culture out of which the
terrorist spring is so different from
ours but i believe the main one to have
been the influence of Christianity
itself there was no inherent conflict
between Islam or others of the world's
major religions and the primitive honor
culture that goes back as far as we have
records and probably a lot further so
the honor culture in Islamic lands has
remained primitive only in Christendom
to give it at his old name did the
dominant religion challenge and even
oppose the honor culture which existed
alongside it when Jesus told his
followers to love your enemies bless
them that curse you do good to them that
hate you and pray for them which
despitefully use you and persecute you
he was speaking directly against the
honor culture which had always demanded
as he pointed out an eye for an eye and
a tooth for a tooth it took centuries
for it to happen but the pressure of
that contradiction eventually but
radically changed the Western Honor
culture producing among other things
codes of chivalry fair play and
gentlemanly pneus that seemed and still
seem outlandish to the rest of the world
as a result we found ourselves getting
out of touch with ideas of Honor even
before our own honor culture started to
go to pieces at the time of the First
World War when honor was blamed for
causing what was up until that time the
bloodiest war the world had ever seen
and as if that weren't enough to other
immensely influential forces were at
work at the same time also partly on
account of the war that further weakened
the honor culture one was feminism and
the other was psychotherapy traditional
honor had always distinguished between
men's and women's honor and that hadn't
changed even after the democratization
and updating of the old and aristocratic
honor culture bike progressive minded
romantics and Victorians during the
previous century in fact there were
still clinging to the updated Victorian
honor culture remnants of the pre-modern
view that a woman's honor by which was
meant her chastity was the property of
her husband or father rather than
herself traditional honor could hardly
have survived the notion of women's
equality meanwhile psychotherapy was
in the process of reversing the honor
cultures traditional subordination of
the individual to the group by elevating
the individual to the social and moral
supremacy he has since enjoyed this
likewise undermined honors foundations
that was how the old honor culture got
so banged up by the time we got to it we
who were and who remained our own cause
when it fell apart pieces of it remained
local honor cultures that survived here
and there the biggest piece was the
military honor culture without which our
soldiers sailors airmen and Marines
could have simply not fight smaller
weaker honor cultures are still found
wherever people are engaged in a
corporate enterprise we all still care
what our family our friends and our
co-workers and professional colleagues
think about us and to that extent these
are all on our groups the nation remains
an honor group to the extent that
patriotism still exists but patriotism
now is usually thought of rather as a
feeling than as an obligation rather as
a warm glow in our hearts than a call to
action it demands nothing of us except
that we obey the law the shared honor
culture that used to belong to everybody
and that taught us not just to love our
country but also how to love it and why
it was lovable is largely gone whether
honor can never make a comeback I am
somewhat skeptical but I want at this
point to set aside questions of
individual honor for another occasion or
perhaps for the question period and talk
instead about national honor for
whatever may be true of the viability of
individuals without of the individuals
without honor within a given society it
seems to me that among nations honor
remains as indispensable as ever it is
our failure to understand this which has
created so many of the foreign policy
disasters of the last half century and
more
it's not fashionable to say this but the
but the Iraq war was about oil or so
wrote John Judas in the New Republic
online the other day I would be the last
person to turn us turn my nose up at the
unfashionable as such but sometimes
things are unfashionable not because
they are true but because they are false
anyway depends on where you stand in
some quarters on the left to say that
the war was about oil is at least as
fashionable as Birkenstocks stocks and
tie dyes indeed insofar as the left has
any reason for being anymore it is to
seek out and expose whether in the
streets or in the pages of the New
Republic just such hidden motives as
this beneath the moralizing rhetoric
used by those in power to justify the
use of military force Kevin Phillips to
thinks that oil is the real reason for
the war but rather confusingly he's
added a second real reason in the shape
of the evangelical interest in
establishing what he calls an American
theocracy fortunately there seems to be
no limit on the number of real reasons
there can be hidden beneath the unreal
ones so we can add to their number the
theory of John mearsheimer and Stephen
Walt set out in the London Review of
Books that the real reason is the
sinister influence of the Israel lobby
neither mr. Judas's nor mr. Phillips's
nor mrs. Muir Chalmers and Walt's
arguments are quite persuasive to me but
I would like to join them in the
favorite game of the anti-war party by
mentioning what I think is the real
reason for the war it is a reason which
like the ones they advance I believed to
have sculpt guiltily behind the publicly
declared ones about weapons of mass
destruction and bringing democracy to
the Iraqi people its name is honor to be
sure I thought that honor would have
been better served by other Wars than
the one that was chosen but it was kind
of hard to have that debate when the
word honor was never mentioned by either
the pro or the anti-war side for to
admit to having gone to war for national
honor as I believe we did as indeed we
always do would I'm afraid have been
thought up by most people even most
Republicans as being at least as
shameful as admitting that we had gone
to war for oil
Christian millinery ins or for the undue
influence of a foreign power why is that
one answer lies in the utopian bias that
the left has imposed upon our political
discourse ever since the war to end wars
in 1914-1918 war has seemed so horrible
to large numbers of people that nothing
less than bringing about permanent peace
or protecting them from the most eminent
of dangers such as weapons of mass
destruction could possibly justify the
doctrine of basic honor that when we or
our friends have been hit by them or
their friends we must hit back has
hardly been hurt since the outrage that
greeted the German rape of Belgium in
1914 even after Pearl Harbor the
official rationale for joining in world
war two was designed to play down
retaliation and revenge and to play up
the idea of the death struggle between
democracy and dictatorship this even
though we ourselves were alight with the
world's bloodiest dictatorship at the
time ever since then the unprecedented
crimes of out of Hitler have served as
almost the only paradigm for an
acceptable casus belli at least if we
had to judge from the frequency with
which the late German dictator's name
comes up in connection with talk of
going to war that's what i call setting
the bar high it also explains why those
on the anti-war left get so cross those
stalin was at least a rival of hitler's
for the title of world's worst dictator
neither his successors in moscow nor Ho
Chi Minh or Saddam Hussein awful as all
of them were were in the same league
thus the idea that Saddam for instance
was another Hitler who had to be stopped
on his march to world domination was so
unpersuasive as to suggest to the wars
opponents rightly I think that it was
merely a mask for some other and less
palatable motivation one that the pro
warriors would not have wanted to come
out apart from anything else the world
is filled with dictators and strong men
who are as bad or worse than set up why
then did we go to war against him rather
than any of the others to people like
John Judas the fact that Iraq was or is
or was the world's second or third
largest oil exporter provides all the
answer they need even though their
Theory hasn't got an answer to the
objection that history affords us no
example of an enemy not even Saddam who
been so dastardly as to refuse to sell
us his oil I think that honour offers a
better theory it's also why i think
polls show that large numbers of
Americans stubbornly persistent in the
belief in the connection between Saddam
and al Qaeda to the anti-war left this
only demonstrates the success of the
administration's propaganda campaign
even though it stopped making that
argument long ago but my belief is that
those what those polls are showing is
public indifference to the question of
the nature and extent of Saddam's links
with Islamist terrorism before the war
like Al Qaeda itself these believers in
the connection between Islamists and
bath is care much more about what has
happened after the war when that
connection has become undeniable though
forged like America's alliance with
Stalin during the Second World War on
the principle that the enemy of my enemy
is my friend it is enough for many
people retro actively to justify the
Bush administration in attacking Saddam
as a retaliation for 911 this is because
most people still instinctively
understand the demands of honor in its
term striking back at someone with only
a distant connection to our attackers is
actually more effective in sending the
message that we and our power are not to
be trifled with or disrespected then
hailing the criminals themselves or
their close associates into court we had
a good illustration of where that leads
last week with the tragicomic end to the
trial of zack arias Mousawi from the
point of view of the honor culture he
represents it made perfect sense for him
to proclaim america you lost i won hard
as it is for us to swallow that is
almost certainly how a large part of the
world that might be tempted into
sympathy with america's most deadly
enemies will see it too opponents of the
death penalty for mr. Mousawi told us
that killing him would only make him a
martyr but better to have another martyr
and if there's one thing the inventors
of suicide bombing are hardly short of
its martyrs and to have an enemy thus
proclaiming his victory over us because
we haven't got the gumption to swat him
like a fly those who deplore america's
cultivation of honor and the fear and
respect among our enemies that go with
it will doubtless say that affording him
all the due process of our criminal law
criminal justice system and then sparing
life because he too must be considered
as one of life's victims is the best
illustration of the superiority of our
system to the savage and brutal honor
culture of our enemies and to them it is
but they should also be aware that to
those within that savage and brutal
culture it is no such thing but merely
one more reason to despise us and then
confirm them in the belief that we don't
have the will to defend ourselves it was
to counter that that belief that in
American weakness and vulnerability that
we went to war in Iraq in the first
place or so my own personal conspiracy
theory would claim and if it wasn't it
should have been but just as Saddam
Hussein tried to look strong by
encouraging our belief in double in his
WMDs but really was weak so our
formidable military presence conceal
another kind of weakness a weakness of
will and determination to make ourselves
respected among those for whom only
violence or a credible threat of its
deployment will engender respect it
seems to me that international relations
among stronger and weaker nations have
always been conducted in terms of this
respect or its absence and unavoidable
that they will continue to be so
conducted in the foreseeable future any
responsible government has got to
consider the national honor as a
precious legacy that many have paid for
in blood and that has to be preserved if
we are to continue to enjoy national
freedom and autonomy as well as to avoid
war with those who in its absence will
find us a soft target if as I suppose
the real reason for the war in Iraq is
for the war in Afghanistan was not for
oil or Jesus or the Israel lobby but the
protection of our national honor and the
reassertion of our right to be respected
by lesser but potentially aggressive
powers who would otherwise be tempted to
become our enemies why should it have
been such a shameful thing for the
administration to admit it as much so
shameful indeed at none of the wars
apologists none that I know of anyway
seems ever to have brought it up even as
one reason among many for America's
resort to arms what made them so afraid
to cite honorable as opposed to moral or
prophylactic reasons for going to war
well just look at what happened the last
time the word honor was heard on the
sweaty lips of an American president
Richard Nixon you may remember
desperately sought peace with honor in
Vietnam by which we and our enemies both
understood the team
and some desperate shift by which he
could save face and avoid the appearance
of a humiliating defeat which would play
havoc with our reputation and
credibility as a military power all
around the world this was the condition
that Nixon himself had so memorably
described in connection with the
Cambodian invasion as America's
reduction to the state of a pitiful
helpless giant needless to say didn't
work Nixon should have remembered the
scandal that had been caused by the
revelation of the Pentagon Papers that
the secret motivations of the architects
of the war were in their words seventy
percent to avoid a humiliating us defeat
to our reputation as guarantor ie honor
and only ten percent to permit the
people of South Vietnam to enjoy a
better freer way of life in the official
propaganda about the war these
proportions were roughly reversed so it
was hardly surprising if people thought
that they had been lied to likewise when
the young John Kerry testified before
senator Fulbright's Foreign Relations
Committee in 1971 his most ringing
indictment of the Nixon administration
was that someone has to die so that
President Nixon won't be and these are
his words the first president to lose a
war to lieutenant Carey as he then was
this concern seemed a merely personal
vanity on Nixon's part a virtual
admission that Vietnam was the quote
mistake which you couldn't ask a man to
die for it's not that lieutenant Carey
considered the argument from honor and
rejected it he never even began to
understand it and in this he was typical
of those in the anti-war party to whom
he was appealing and then then and who
have continued to protest against
America's war wars including the one in
Iraq today ever since so influential has
the antianna party become that no
president since Nixon has dared to make
even the negative and oblique appeal to
honor that he did in justification of
the deployment of America's troops
abroad though I believe that honor has
continued to be the unacknowledged
motivation behind such deployments it's
a discouraging thought for believers in
national honor like myself and I'm
afraid I can offer no good reasons for
thinking that a greater frankness on the
part of the administration about the
honorable roots of its policies in Iraq
and elsewhere would be greeted by
anything but howls of outrage from its
opponents and probably many of its
dwindling bands of supporters as well
for thirty years and more we have been
schooled
in the therapeutic belief that we are or
ought to be our own cause so that even
when there is as I have said in
connection with the al-qaeda Saddam link
an instinctive but mute understanding of
honors demands we no longer have the
vocabulary with which to express it if
my book does something to reintroduce
that vocabulary into our national
discourse it will at least be a first
step thank you john o'sullivan please
well Chris mr. chairman thank you for
the kind remarks he made about me
earlier I'm grateful to hear them and
Jim thank you for a splendid
presentation having read your book I
wasn't surprised by it and I did leave
some space at the beginning of my talk
to to disagree with you but in fact I
don't generally disagree with you which
is why I think most of my remarks are
going to be directed to your book rather
than to what you've just said a moment
ago at the very end I will disagree on
one point or rather develop one point
well first of all let me say about mr.
Bowman's book although this is not a
book review it is a splendid book it
unravels the complexities of a very
tangled moral come social concept very
clearly indeed it does so extremely Rida
bleah it illustrates a powerful argument
with examples drawn from high and low
culture that in examples that are in
themselves fascinating see in particular
his reflections on the film the life and
death of colonel blimp when you buy the
book and it is very largely correct not
politically correct simply correct which
is quite different in fact I would say
that being a reviewer of Honor I I read
the book from beginning to end but if
you want to treat it as a kind of
chocolate box into which you can dip
occasionally for pleasure I think it
works very well that way too now I want
to begin my reflections on on his
arguments in the following way I want to
do so by reference to a very topical
film united 93 which is just out now in
which you probably read about because it
seems to me that we see in that film a
clash between two very different notions
of honor first of all there is the
notion of honor which the terrorists the
islamist radicals have in their own mind
about themselves they have a very
primitive notion of honor which is
described in the Indians book they are
in fact its embodiment I should say that
nobody makes speeches in this film we
have to sort of speak in third
opinions from from their actions but
those actions are extremely eloquent
because their honor and its actions at
these their honor demands the punishment
of any insult can dine ly there on a
consists of the mixture of piety and
courage they pray and they have a kind
of high-strung bravery which carries
them through most though not all of the
hijacking they are entirely lacking
however in mercy or compassion they
murder three people in the cause of the
hijacking these murders are not strictly
necessary to their purpose though they
serve the purpose perhaps of
intimidating everybody else and in fact
in some respects they complicate their
business that eventually they complicate
the project of destroying the Capitol
building but this willingness to murder
at random so to speak stems from their
contempt for those outside their own
honor group people who lack honor that
includes of course the passengers of the
plane but also includes virtually
everyone living in the United States now
do the American passengers really lack
honor as the terrorists imagine no they
demonstrate that conclusively by
fighting back by attempting to take
control of the cockpit and by being
prepared to die in the attempt but their
honor is very different indeed from the
honor of the terrorists it is different
in the following ways first of all it is
up to a point prudent even instrumental
while the passengers think that the
hijacking may result simply in their
being inconvenienced unpleasantly for
several days but they eventually return
to their families and they even though
they're obviously not enjoying the
experience they are prepared to be
passive it is when they learn of the
destruction of the World Trade Center
and the Pentagon and for see their own
fate in the same way that they fight
back
retrieve their honor they proved
themselves to be by any standard of
honor Western or not worthy of respect
but this honor is compatible with tender
feelings and the expression of emotion
it is not essentially stoic they bid
loving farewell to their families and
friends over the telephone they weep
some of the people who weep go on to
step down straight great bravery um they
the most tender emotions however in no
way imply appeasement they attack one
man a European I thought that was
slightly overrating the pudding myself
who contrives to our continues to argue
for passivity even when it is clear that
the terrorists are bent upon their
deaths they were overpowering
restraining and um finally the honor of
the passengers is self-sacrificial the
most important point it seems to me the
the passengers seek to stop the
terrorists they seek to get control of
the plane even though this is likely to
result in there more immediate deaths
than then postponement partly they do it
because in a sense they can't think of a
better alternative there isn't one and
partly they feel the terrorists want to
aim the plane at another iconic target
like the Pentagon or the World Trade
Center and they want to frustrate that
purpose so let's go quickly over that
they want to protect others they want to
frustrate the terrorists and they don't
go like lambs to the slaughter in all
these ways the Americans retrieve their
honor as I say by any standard they also
demonstrate that genuine honor is
compatible with other virtues such as
prudence and mercy and in the end they
win that is to say the terrorists don't
achieve what they set out to achieve and
by frustrating the terrorists not only
have they reacted more swiftly than
anyone could conceivably have imagined
to the new world of
11 this happens one hour after the whole
thing starts they demonstrate it seems
to me that the concept of Honor held by
Americans and most Western people is not
only morally superior so the primitive
honor code of the Islamists but is also
superior by the acid test of material
success or a practical success rather
now Jim's book is an explanation is
built on exploring the different
concepts of honor that here displayed
and other ones as well he examines how
the Western nations notions of Honor
which began is pretty similar to those
two other primitive honor codes
gradually developed along they were
originally they worthy they were
concerned with the Warriors public
reputation they became something much
more complicated under the influence of
an principally Christianity later
romanticism and so on he sees the I'm
sorry I can't be been writing it he
seems the clash that is likely to
develop between this concept of Honor
and other ones as in United 93 and he
worries that the western code of honor
is disappearing because it is
increasingly overwhelmed by the other
virtues which it wants with once it held
in fruit itself in fruitful tension to
you might say that the art primitive
notions of Honor correspond to what
surely Robin let when called the
vigorous virtues Western honor gradually
assimilated the softer virtues into
itself and these softer virtues are now
in for undermining and overwhelming the
vigorous virtues which aren't which with
which the concept on which the concept
is of fundamentally rooted now my 53
questions to raise the first is what
tamed Knightly honor in the first place
after all it was originally socially
exclusive the preserve of military
elites well it begins it seems to me
me and much of what I'm saying is going
to drawn on what I've learned from gym
but I hope I'm adding value as well as
they say these days it became a
universal moral possibility even an
universal moral aspiration as virtue
it's as violence itself was tamed by the
modern state dueling lingered on for
some time in some places but by the turn
of the 20th century a gentleman did not
need to carry around a sword now he
might need to carry around something
else as I say dueling a gentlemanly
ideal is often thought to be socially
exclusive and it began that way but the
sociologist and wit Kristy Davis and
sociologists and Witter not often found
in the same sentence refers to describe
something that a workman at the turn of
the 20th century carried around with him
he called it his character and this was
a testimony that a previous employer had
made not to his occupational skills but
to his moral virtues his diligence his
sobriety his decency his failure is non
drunkenness um and this was as much an
expression of the gentlemanly ideal as
something in Jane Austen a second way in
which the Western notion of Honor
developed was it changed from a
defensive ones public reputation in
Marshall terms to the cultivation of
private moral virtues there's a lot of
amusing stuff in Jim's book about
Lancelot and Guinevere how everybody
knows that they're having the fur but
that everybody pretends not to know it
so that the question of whether or not
they're having an affair can be settled
by Lancelot defeating those Rascals who
allege he is if he defeats them he's not
having an affair if he doesn't well he's
in trouble oh now this kind this concept
of Honor as a public defense of
reputation and which can be determined
by physical bravery this was changed
out of all recognition to become the
possession of genuine private virtues
probity of one kind or another but
always it seems to me always allied with
courage courage in men and chasidy and
women are so to speak the shorthand of
honor and thirdly as la honor lost its
Marshall explanation its Marshall
character it gained a different sort of
Marshall character it became something
becomes replied to the gentleman that he
would lend his assistance to the week
two women certainly but two other weak
people as well when Harvey Mansfield was
speaking in Washington a few weeks ago I
raised the question of whether or not
people who people who stopped bullying
were manly which he agreed but he also
thought that the bullies might
conceivably be regarded as manly too now
whether or not that's true the bullies
certainly are not gentlemanly and it
would and dr. Arnold of rugby Oh
regarded one of his aims as to stamp out
bullying by cultivating the gentlemanly
code in his boys that they would step in
and stop it and as late as the 1950s
when I was at school that was very much
the theory we were taught so all in all
honor in it was demonstrated in women
sorry by protecting women and the week
the result of this blending of the
vigorous virtues traditional honor with
the virtues such as compassion it is
what Jim calls the Vatican evict Orion
synthesis Arnold of rugby I've mentioned
muscular Christianity the dissemination
of this set of ideals throughout the
anglo-american world and can I just
borrow the book is that there's one
wonderful passage in page 98 in which
Morris Samuel
so I was not 19 n I've written 90 able
to doesn't seem to be on 98 oh yes Mara
Samuel who was a Romanian Jewish
immigrant to Manchester lair read the
schoolboy literature at the time and was
in trance by it it was scuba literature
you may even have read yourself even
today Tom not just Tom Brown school days
but also Tom mary billy bunter books and
so on and he says in in them among us
Jewish youngsters wrote Samuel honor
bright was used as often as in the
stories of grey fires the code also
included the stiff upper lip which was
as tacit Lee at part of a decent fellows
equipment as it was unthinkable to be a
bully it would have horrified us to be
told that a bully could keep a stiff
upper lip just like Tom Mary or Harry
Wharton bullying was among the
unforgivable sins I remember Arnold
bikeman saying that exactly the same
thing about his upbringing in the united
states that he read these novels and he
thought this was a superior moral code
to the ones that he saw about him um you
know there's a saying that no lady can
be a gentleman but even that is open to
doubt in the in the novels in her
classic study of the novels of anthony
trollope surely Robin alert win points
out that on trollop zone criteria the
best example of a gentleman in his
novels is madam max she was a Jew a
foreigner a radical and a woman but the
Duke of omnium the most admired and
prominent man in England proposed
marriage to her and which more or less
establishes her status and she was
sufficiently confident of that
gentlemanly status to refuse him since
there was an element of condescension in
them now as the late Victorian and
Edwardian the concept of Western honor
the gentleman it spread it spread in a
way more widely than we can quite grasp
today I'm going to give you two examples
of it
two examples which are an example of the
self sacrifice which is the severus test
of gentlemanly behavior one is the
Titanic of course there a number of
stories like that my favorite is
Benjamin book at Duggan Himes remark he
told the light all of the first mate he
was he wasn't on he wouldn't get in the
lifeboats while the women and children
are there he said mr. Lightoller if you
survive I would be grateful if you would
tell my wife that I behaved decently and
of course there is to show that these
virtues went right down the social scale
there is the famous case of the Burton
ahead a troopship but on its way to
South Africa struck a rock was sinking
fast in order to allow the women and
children to escape in the lifeboats the
Royal Marlene Marines lined up
information on deck and stayed
information as the ship sank as Kipling
said to stand and be still to the
birkenhead drill is a damn tough bullet
to chew but they did it cetera cetera so
here you had an ideal that was very very
hard to live up to and yet it spread
worldwide I don't believe any concept of
Honor has had the kind of international
dominant cultural authority that that
one did at the turn of the 19th to the
20th century it didn't just expand it
wasn't it obvious lead us in England it
wasn't just in the British Empire it
wasn't of course in the simply in the
great American Republic though it was in
all of those places but it was in those
informal empires like countries informal
imperial countries like Argentina or
even the Continental countries like
Italy which looked at the
english-speaking world now that being
the case we have to explain why did it
collapse because as I say I don't
believe any other concept of Honor which
are explored in gyms workers have that
kind of them have had that kind of pit
of peel yes I can see you
and I can't read mine writing that
phrase pity because I know that was a
good point now why did it collapse well
there are a number of reasons given by
Jim in the book the first world war is
obviously one of the main ones second is
feminism and so on I think candidly
better three first there is the advance
of the regulatory state um gentlemanly
honor always kept was rooted after all
in the notion of self-reliance you can't
stop bullying if you yourself are likely
to be bullied you have to be able to
stand on your own two feet and only and
self-reliance therefore is something
which has to be maintained if the
gentlemanly honor code is to be
maintained but the regulatory state
gradually reduces the need for
self-reliance after all it's looking
after you and when it does so it also
makes self-reliance more difficult
financially and in other ways because
what was originally helped to other
people begins to seem to be the
usurpation of functions that should be
properly carried out by the government
the second I would say is the advance of
the the development of the regulatory
state into the therapeutic state and
with mr. tell here I don't intend to say
anything more about that she can deal
with that in questions and then finally
there is multiculturalism which casts
doubt on all standards of behavior which
are not readily explicable on the basis
of some criterion like need so that the
standards of behavior gentlemen could
either would either have to be abandoned
or they would have to be explained to
everybody from first principles and that
simply is not practical so that's why I
declined can it then survive well it is
never entirely disappeared Jim himself
concedes amid much pessimism that he
himself is a tree increasingly attracted
to it um has been against his will
almost attracted to it I have to say
precisely the same thing my opinions
were not always what they are now and I
gradually found myself more and more
thinking that this was a wonderful ideal
which the loss of which would be
terrible it seems to me that honor is
imprinted on the human heart and that
the gentlemanly concept of honor is more
fully that more fully appeals to the
human heart than any other that explains
its international dominance so I suppose
that honor killings might conceivably
appeal to people outside the culture in
which they grew but I don't see any
evidence of it and I don't think it at
all likely there are cases of there's no
doubt that many of these ideals are
cross-cultural the case for example
courage is also always cross-cultural we
can admire examples of courage from in
tribes which otherwise strikers is
completely unknowable but it is possible
here's my final point it is possible
that because of the growth of regulation
therapeutic state in the series of other
social developments honor will simply
gradually disappear leaving behind
simply a nostalgic flavor in literature
on the other hand let me say that I find
it hard to imagine this happening
because i think it's imprinted in human
heart i think that that it is therefore
something which will always be capable
of being revived and realized i see some
evidence of this in a number of ways at
the moment mr. Mansfield's book Jim's
book the behavior of people in the film
united 93 which was after all behavior
in real life and the reaction of
Americans to 911 across the society
which led to greater admiration for
heroism people like like policemen and
firemen which intruded even to such
unlikely places as sex in the city so
Jim's pessimism about a revival of Honor
seems to me to reflect a very sensible
skepticism about the moral and
intellectual elites who dominate our
culture at the moment but whether or not
on the survives will really come down to
the question
of whether or not we have enough honor
to fight for it John thank you very much
I'm going to turn immediately to
questions from everybody assembled here
because I know that there will be there
will be many there will be a floating
microphone if you'll please wait for a
second until the microphone arrives and
introduce yourself we'll start with this
gentleman whom I will introduce as David
from David thank you both Jim I've had a
chance to read the book and it is indeed
of a marvel it's witty it's it's
learning it's and it's very provocative
and and we're all in your debt I want to
ask you about another film than United
93 with Sean referred to a much shorter
film that was distributed by the
Department of Defense last week it was
the film that showed the terrorists are
cowie miss using a rifle and one of his
followers burning his hands because he
doesn't know enough not to hold the
barrel of the gun in and do you think
this kind of tactic of ridicule and
belittlement is effective in opposing a
traditional honor culture or do you
think it's counterproductive and that
now somebody likes our cow he has to go
kill even more people to prove that he's
not a big as full as the Americans make
him out today I think I think both
things can be true i think i think it is
effective as a in fact perhaps the most
effective thing that we that we can do
to to make to make them look ridiculous
is is a humiliating experience and one
which is particularly humiliating within
the context of that of that honor
culture the point the point is not what
it will do to mr. Zarqawi that I mean
presumably it will make him very cross
but what what effect it will have on his
relationship to his followers and I
think if he loses credibility in there
their eyes
a good thing can be only a good thing
for us and for the world so I'm all for
it I think it's a good idea Ben
wattenberg thank you Chris of course we
should not be surprised that Jim Bowman
came up with a brilliant disquisition we
expect that however I unlike John
O'Sullivan I really have some points of
disagreement I first of all I look at
the podium there and I see three men of
honor I traveled with the john mccain in
two thousand and he said that what we
his best line was we need a cause larger
than ourselves um george w bush I heard
him last week speak about the war and he
said and repeated I have not lost my
nerve that is the only way we will lose
this war as if I lose my nerve he and
Vice President Cheney have said from day
one that what they have to do is prove
American staying power that the idea
that we have a failed foreign policy
having achieved the status of an omni
power never seen before I I don't think
is true and let me close on the movie
metaphor if I might in this very room
the very first large session we had was
based on the popular culture and the
Academy award-winning director Sydney
[ __ ] said in American movies the hero
shapes destiny which is an honorable
concept
do you want me yeah I think that's right
I don't I wouldn't be understood to be
saying that the Iraq is a is a foreign
policy disaster i hope i hope i didn't
convey that impression i I don't think
it is it failed and I do agree that that
President Bush has not lost his nerve
and is all the more honorable for it but
at the point I was I was making is that
for all that we recognize the
experiences of Vietnam and of Iraq are
different they have this in common that
the real reasons for the war could not
be expressed in public and and I think
that that's crippled our effort there as
it will do wherever--wherever the same
thing happens yes sir I'm related
Prakash from India and I saw this a
certain resurgence of of reclaiming
honor in India which wasn't very good
and that was the Hindu tour thing that
happened in Gujarat and that prompted me
to write a book called him to 30
mystified now or here my problem is that
of what we usually have in economics
that of aggregation I find the concept
of Honor group very interesting worth
pursuing but when we started getting
groups and make it a national level
thing then I think they've come very
many problems which you might have
discussed in the book but i would like
to throw some light on that my question
is is there an honor which which applies
to those who are rich who have lots of
armaments who have got everything in
life and then there is a middle class
which is trying to go up which is also
trying to prevent slipping down and then
there is a third loss of people who
don't probably have enough to eat who
can't defend themselves against
iniquitous order of society or bullies
or all that so if we divide society in
three levels then do you think there
will be three concepts of honor thank
I don't I don't think I don't think
that's that's the case I'm not sure
whether you're referring to America or
India or some generic society I America
no I do I think I think one of the one
of the things about America is is the
it's sort of unitary culture from the
point of view not only a vulnerable of
other things as well I mean that there
are two be sure differences in economic
success among are among our people but
the good but the culture is remarkably
uniform and I think you'd find the same
attitudes to honor in in the very
highest and in the very lowest people in
our society that would be able to be my
my impression my name is Philip terzian
both Jim and John O'Sullivan ascribed
the decline of the Western honor culture
Jimmy ascribed it in part to the rise of
psychotherapy without fully explaining
what that means and as if everyone in
the room knew why it was to blame I was
well maybe we could just expand on that
a little bit sure in fact i'd like to uh
it's the one thing I did want to mention
in respect to what John John was saying
because I had a slightly different
impression of United 93 then then then
he did I thought like him that it was a
it was a good film and very gripping and
paid a tribute to the people on that
plane who fought back but I had some
slight reservations because it it was
known and it was evident in the film
that the heroism of the the four men
that we know were the greatest of the
heroes Todd Beamer Tom Burnett Jeremy
Glick and Mark Bingham were downplayed
and this was in response to the concerns
of the families on that on that fly he
Paul Greengrass the director of the film
deliberately set out to have the
cooperation in agreement of all the
families in it
that he did in that in that film and
thought it was for that reason that none
of those men were named and that in the
melee of the counter-attack there were
they they were not that the camera did
not pick them out to distinguish them it
was it was shown as a sort of universal
heave by the passengers towards the
cockpit and the reason for that was as
some of the some of the families
explicitly said that we don't think
there were four heroes we think there
were 40 they were all equally a heroic
now what that comes from I mean these
these were people who thought their
relatives would have been dishonored by
not being counted among the four the
four men we knew were the leaders of the
counter-attack it seems to me that comes
from the doctrine of self-esteem which
is in a way what we what the therapeutic
culture is substituted for honor honor
what the one thing it cannot be is even
equally distributed it goes to those who
merited and if it goes to everybody then
nobody merits it everybody gets it as of
right and that's what self-esteem is
self-esteem is honor as of right which
is not honor at all and that it's in
that way particularly that I think the
therapeutic culture has undermined and
almost made impossible honor as
traditionally understood I hope that
answers your question the Chris levenach
from AEI Jim Lydon I'd like to point out
a necessary correlative honor shame and
acknowledge my own shame and not having
read your book yet you've given us an
awful lot to think about and I look
forward to doing so but I'd like to
explore the notion of shame as applied
to individuals it seems to me it still
persists and being the flipside of honor
is that not some indication that a bit
of the honor culture are diluted to be
sure up transformed and narrowed still
exists the two examples i'm thinking of
shame that's sort of
is it picking up that's that still
centers around City or that still
centers around a rigorous judgmentalism
I mean these are two things they're
widely shamed echoes of the honor
culture there's a there's a passage in
my book in the in it begin it wouldn't i
think it's chapter 11 begins with an
episode of the sopranos which i think is
a marvelous of television series
illustrating it it is in fact the whole
thing the whole all five seasons of it
so far a perfect illustration of where
honor does survive and how far this this
is still with us it's with us though in
a kind of vestigial sense as we see in
in in a particular bit that I I pick out
there is a there is a be for a potential
revenge a question of revenge coming up
when one of the Mafia people says
something derogatory about the wait the
the the size of the wife of a of another
one and this man appeals to traditionals
and the traditional sense of honor
Johnny Sack is his name his wife is very
large indeed and she has an eating
disorder it's described in explicitly
therapeutic terms and and the joke the
joke that the the other the other man
says infuriates Johnny himself and he
demands satisfaction he actually uses
that word presumably without knowing the
history of that of that expression in
honor honor societies and the other the
other people both his own capo his own
boss and and mr. soprano who is the boss
of the other guy get together and they
scratch their heads and they can't
figure I mean in a way it is like the
old days when when a woman's honor was
compromised the involved her husband in
fighting for it and fighting to the
death indeed or taking revenge if you
if you're a mafia mafioso but on this
occasion but but but what would
compromise woman's honor in the old days
was was an imputation of unchastity the
idea that she had she had been granting
her favors to someone not her husband in
this case the idea that someone had
called her fat when she quite obviously
was fat was was a puzzler but but there
was there was some considerable set the
sentiment that in fact yes this was this
was a dispute and and and carmine the
boss of Johnny's it says well okay we'll
tax him we will charge him two hundred
thousand dollars for saying for saying
that his wife is too fat it's I mean
these guys these kind of vestigial
remains of Honor I certainly continue
certainly continue to exist but they
they exist partly because I think you're
right we can't we can't do without in my
in the book I also distinguish between
what I call the the reflexive honor and
and and cultural honor and cultural
honors is the way we we make sense of
these things in the old days the
cultural honor of the Mafia would have
known just what how to proceed in that
situation now they're as much at sea as
the rest of us because we don't have a
cultural honor anymore we have is that
reflexive honor that when we're insulted
we have to stand up for ourselves and
fight back and I think the same is true
of shame probably we still instinctively
feel shame about about certain things
but we don't have any language to
describe about to ourselves when we
should feel shame and when we should
feel on it mark plattener I thought that
was a marvelous lecture gym but I'm
afraid I am one of those who haven't
read the book as yet it's for sale
outside and I wondered in the Cadillac
of various destroyers of honor that have
been listed ranging from Christianity to
the therapeutic effect and Freud and so
on one common enemy or enemies and would
be in some common accounts of this is
not mentioned which would be capitalism
or the bourgeois effect
and which is often seen as being
countered to the warrior or aristocratic
I think and I wonder if this is
something that and you discuss it all in
the book whether you view it in that way
or what your take on that would be I
think the that that was that was often
said that at the time of the of the
revolution that I talked about that well
that was the wide Napoleon called
Britain a nation of shopkeepers they
were he to that to him that meant they
could have no no honor but what the
Victorians accomplished in that in that
in that synthesis that I that I
mentioned was the the really
revolutionary idea that you could be
bourgeois you could be from the middle
classes and still be honorable and that
and and it was as I say as much American
Americans as anybody else and there were
probably more Americans than anybody
else in the world who who who created
that idea first they found the founding
fathers were among the first to to
democratize honor in that in that sense
so I don't see no I don't don't see a
problem with that at least not for the
last 200 years oh hello Fradkin I also
want to say that I enjoyed the lecture
very much Jim and I really look forward
to reading the book I wanted to ask a
question that relates to the comparison
you've drawn I gather the book but also
in the lecture between the honor culture
of contemporary radical Muslims and
which as you know i'm particularly
preoccupied with and the spectrum of of
such cultures you pick in particular
than the phrase death before dishonor no
and that surely is a you know a minimum
condition of
any notion of honor there's a
willingness to die if that's what it
means to maintain your honor and of
course it is very much part of Islamist
rhetoric to say that americans or
Westerners are not willing to do that
and hence their contemptible and also
defeatable and that of course is
obviously not true but what seems very
strange about the Islamist discourse and
I was wondering if it's unique in this
regard is it's not merely that def that
you have to be willing to face death for
honor but but positively welcoming it
mmm is the honorable thing to do yeah
and it's I'm not sure this was
particularly true of Islam in the past I
sort of scratched my head about this a
little bit but it's certainly true of
its current rhetoric that there is a
longing for death and the definition of
that long as being the constituent of
honor is there any other example of that
in the past or is this really something
quite unique in the definition of arland
ah I don't know of anything that's quite
quite like that i bought it but i
absolutely right that you see you see
that again and again we wheel of death I
mean the famous formulation of I forget
in was at Osama or somebody's that we
love death more than you love life and
at what what that intended to convey it
seems to me was aren't you afraid of me
if I'm if I am that if I've regard my
own life with that with that much
contempt I I I embrace death and
therefore you should you should be
afraid of me but it is as you say a
rhetorical device it's like and and and
and President Bush was much ridiculed
for this when he said bring it on it's
the same kind of thing I'm not afraid of
you and that's that's what these kinds
of things always always convey you know
you can't you can't you can't hurt me
you can't do anything meat I you know
I'm not afraid of death or you know
bring it on is it's that it's that kind
of fighting fighting rhetoric but it has
a particularly unlovely quality I think
in that in that those examples that you
talked about that love of death sort of
sort of thinking good I mean it goes
together with suicide bombing which has
been way of sort of practical
demonstration that they they love death
which which is as I say not not very
attractive to our sideline I'm Kyle
vandermeulen I work here at AEI this was
a fascinating talk and I'm really
looking forward to reading your book I
have a lot of questions but I guess
broadly speaking how can you reconcile
this sort of schizophrenic nature that
we can base major foreign policy
decisions off of honor but yet we can't
talk about it what when more
specifically what is it that will
perpetuate honor in our in national
honor Mr O'Sullivan mentioned that an
individual honor he thinks it's on the
heart what is national honor and what
perpetuates is it the democracy that we
have built is it sort of like the
cultural system and and how can we not
talk about it I think it I think it
comes from the fact that we we have we
aren't in the days when national honor
was strong and was easily spoken of we
regarded ourselves and those who
believed in nash National Honor regarded
themselves as the bearers of
civilization and and and that not only
was our honor good for us it was good
for everyone because we we were we had
something that the rest of the world
needed to get from us and it's that
self-confidence I think that we've
that's been taken away from us by the
political left over the last 70 or 80
years by in particular the stressing of
the Imperial and racist adventures of of
our country and of other countries where
we've had such an adventures and and the
emphasis of on the victimhood of those
who supposedly have been damaged and
harmed by by it it is I don't think we
can overestimate the importance of that
loss of self-confidence and it's liat
what leads to one of the other things
that John mentioned is this
multiculturalism is this belief that all
cultures are equally worthy of respect
and our own we are just humble people
and we're not going to threaten anyone
because because your culture is just as
good as mine it's that if that which
which is produced what we are talking
about here Jim hi I'm Peter woloson at
AEI I want to just talk a little bit
about your or have you talked a little
bit about your definition of honor
because as I recall you said it is being
respected by others whom you respect or
something to that effect now I'm going
to use a phrase here that sounds a
little sociological and that is it
sounds to me as though it's somewhat
outer directed that is to say very out
of directly you would be you would this
honor would come from the opinions of
others rather than coming from inside
can you reconcile those two for me maybe
I don't understand the concept entirely
yeah it we I stress again the the the
primitive nature and the and the bits of
honor that remain primitive and that's
one of them I think it always is
other-directed it always has this public
element which differentiates it from for
morality and we we can't decide
ourselves whether we will be honored or
not only other people can decide that
and therefore it's necessarily other
other-directed but the Western tradition
of honor unlike other traditions has
spent hundreds of years it can
persuading us and and and I go through
that I go through this in the book
persuading us that the inner and the
outer ought to coincide and that there's
nothing worse
than the hypocrisy of those who pretend
to that kind of outward respect but
inwardly are undeserving of it and
that's that's what you see again and
again in Western literature as opposed
to other literature's other celebrate
heroes the Western hero is the hero
whose inner qualities and and whose
reputation are made to coincide and if
there and if they don't he he's not a
hero anymore it's it's a sort of tragic
element in in Western culture that you
don't you don't find elsewhere and so it
still is what it is in the in in those
primitive honor cultures it still is
your reputation but the one of the
differences with our culture is that the
reputation also what needs to correspond
with the inner life Alex Pollock of AE I
gym among all of the causes for the
decline of Honor John and his comments
added the rise and the flourishing of
the regulatory state yeah do you agree
with that addition and we're in in the
list week honors of honor would that be
in your view I'd unless I I don't
disagree with it but I think it's a
question of chicken and egg which which
came first the regulatory state or the
collapse of honor and I think I think it
was probably the other way around I
don't know whether John insists on the
priority of the regulator is day but I
would say that the regulatory state
comes in to fill a vacuum when when
honor is already on its way downhill for
other for other reasons but it certainly
doesn't help in it it is part of what
makes it obsolete you know in our time
yeah you say I mean I don't entirely
agree with that as a matter of fact
partly because I think what do you see
and this is the period really from about
1900 s age of nineteen forty-five and
maybe even later what you see is the
continuation of social patterns of
behavior that clearly are inspired by
traditional Western notions of Honor
with the advance of the regulatory state
very often people like you know
major a plea I think a conspicuously
honorable person in those terms being
among those who are advancing the
regulatory state in ways which then
undermine the virtues of which they are
ornaments so so I mean I think it
probably works both ways or in the each
reinforces the other but having said
that I do think that probably the
advance of regulation came first and
Kristy Davis whom I realize that no
matter this argues that the very that
once regulation becomes a major element
in criminology particularly then
categories of guilt and innocence and
responsibility cease to matter so much
as bureaucratic categories and people
are not sentenced in terms of did they
behave with particular viciousness but
does their behavior conform to certain
abstract bureaucratic categories which
some of which will obtain and will
deserve will not deserve exactly but
will receive heavier punishments than
others could add a brief word here
because I think it's important to
understand we're not talking about EPA
or the federal communications commission
but the rise of administrative
government including the criminal law
and essentially the delegation from
private society to formal abra
apparatuses the jobs of determining
guilt and innocence justice and i would
say importantly the application of
violence so that individuals have long
since have long since ceased to believe
that the application of violence is
anything that they do or is close to
them it is organized its professional
and in in recent decades we see this at
the international level you have to go
to the Security Council you have to get
a resolution before violence can be
applied in relations between states and
when we made our case there it was a
very legalistic case if secretary
Paulson said our honor has been
besmirched and we are going to reclaim
it the
members of the Security Council wouldn't
have known what to think of it and so I
think that this this growth of the
division of labor and the specialization
in determinations and especially the
application of violence it seems to me
to have been an important cause of the
decline of the idea of violence and some
things that if you were to revive it in
a postmodern form so to speak you would
have to contend with yes I agree with
that but I to again I'd say the to
proceed pari passu it's a it's an
example another example of what what Sir
Henry main called is the transition from
status to contract it's just it's the
way Western civilization has been moving
for hundreds of years really but it
particularly the pates gathered you're
not against all of that you know I'm
sort of it alone I'm not again with all
of that but i think but i think it's i I
think it ought to be possible to arrive
at some at some balance as the
Victorians did I mean I'd be sorry to
think otherwise anyway although I can
see the argument that that it's a sort
of an inevitable quasi Marxist process
of you know the march of history can't
be turned back with Walton yes yes now
this is related to a question LLS and
wallapers of AR the question of the
problem is it is Lana says who can kill
themselves because they love to die
scenes anyone has to raise the question
why they love to die I raised this
because because before coming here I
read to reread Tocqueville's chapter on
the owner and there's some tension
between honor and the benefit than one
might derive these people who love to
die may love to die because their
promise 30 virgins you know now in the
first place I wonder if they're not
virgin to go around I think we're doing
all the killing but still there's a
benefit to it and it seems to me there's
a question as to one can regard and act
as honorable if there's this kind of
benefit
I'm afraid I have to say I I don't
believe that they do love death I don't
believe that they really think they're
going to have 30 or 72 or any number of
virgins afterwards I think it's well
some of them may i'm not i don't i don't
think it's impossible that they that
some of them believe that but i think to
a large extent the the rhetoric of being
in love with death is is just that it's
a it's a it's a way of saying look at me
how terrifying i am because I I spit in
the face of death as some of those boys
comics of of our youth I used to put it
it's that kind of that kind of defiance
rather than anything they actually they
actually believe are many most of them I
would think yes yes I think there that
could be but I think generally in honor
cultures what's what's valued most is
the deed you know it does he do it or
doesn't he do it well you know whether
he thought he was going to get 72
virgins or whether he thought he was you
know going to get something else out of
it the important thing is I mean
somebody for instance also on the New
Republic website Lee Siegel was saying
you know well these guys weren't really
heroes because they didn't have any
choice but to fight today were going to
die anyway so you know wasn't having it
was kind of downplaying the heroism for
that rude what the who cares it doesn't
matter they did the honorable thing what
you know whatever whatever mixed
motivations they may had that's that's
another element of the therapeutic
culture that I was talking about you
know we we think what matters is whether
whether the motivation was right what to
the honor culture traditionally it's
whether you do the deed or whether you
don't Gertrude Himmelfarb be crystal yes
both you Jim and John use the term
multiculturalism well and you both use
the word critical thing um but isn't
there a kind of multiculturalism or
relativism in your own definition of
honor that is isn't Islamic honor or for
that matter Nazi honor as honorable as
our honor
I had a feeling that John tried to
mitigate this notion of honor by
introducing the idea of softer virtues
compensating for the more vigorous
virtues but would you two want to
qualify that term for that reason and
how relativistic are you prepared to be
in connection with this concept of Honor
well let me say and I think it's not me
who's relative is he I think it's honor
is relativistic by its very nature
because as I say it's about an honor
group and within that group an action is
honorable if I stand outside the group
it doesn't mean you know the the Nazis
or they or the whoever don't care
whether I I think they were honorable or
not that all they care is whether
they're the people in their own group at
the same time I think it is true to say
there is a kind of overlap and it comes
up in respect to the Confederate flag
which I which I discussed briefly in in
my book I think it's possible to say to
respect the honor of someone you
profoundly disagree with because there
is there is some kind of overlap a kind
of common language that that honorable
people in all cultures will be able to
speak and and among those is the
recognition that even people who are
very bad people in lots of ways can
behave in this very limited respect
honorably and for that reason i don't i
don't see a problem with honoring the
confederate flag not because it was the
flag of slave owners but because it was
the flag of honorable men who happened
to be among other things slave owners I
just come along this thanks um yes first
of all I think that honor is does emerge
from particular cultures although it is
interesting that when it emerges first
it's but there's a very strong family
resemblance between all these different
sorts of warrior on a virtuous secondly
the it can be as i mentioned i think
courage for example which is always a
component of allah
can be admired across cultures my
favorite example is the case of Smith's
last patrol in which this group of
British South African Police went out in
the matter Billy war were all
slaughtered as they were in their final
moments they they they they brought a
bullets that he withdrew this they drew
their swords sang god save the king or
queen I can't remember and and then ran
out and were all slaughtered now how do
we know this well we know it because the
matter Billy at the end of the war took
the British to the graves where they've
been buried with full matter Billy
military honors so this was a
recognition across cultures of courage
now where I think I'm you did in fact
diagnose me rightly I do think that
Western concepts of on the Western
traditions of honor attempting to
incorporate within them and the softer
virtues to compensate us being
restrained soften the vigorous virtues
and do think that they broaden the
appeal cultural appeal of Western
traditions of our so that the owner
group is I don't say it's potentially
the entire human race but it certainly
proved to be a very large chunk of the
human race or circa 1900 and therefore
um although I although I I think there's
an element of poverty cultural
relativism in this it's a it's one which
in our traditions i think is is
extremely limited and in principle at
least capable of being overcome entirely
I ladies and gentlemen it is time to
conclude I said at the beginning that
this was an astonishingly original a
piece of work it has revived many old
ideas and it has transformed them in my
view the greatest contribution of what
Jim Bowman has done beyond the intrinsic
interest of the work itself is as we've
seen I think the beginning of in this
conversation this afternoon to give us a
new vocabulary a new way of thinking
about and talking about some matters
that were familiar but in part confused
and I think
this contribution is going to prove to
be very deep indeed john o'sullivan
thank you very much for coming in for
your contributions most of all I'd like
to thank and congratulate and asked us
all to give a warm round of applause to
James Bond James Bowman is